biden couldn't remember who the health
and human services secretary is and
frankly most of you probably can't
either because we never see him that's
because it's secretary becerra and he's
been totally absent but sarah has yet to
attend a single white house coveted
briefing think about it he's health and
human services secretary he hasn't
attended one white house briefing on
this he hasn't held a press conference
on the matter and it took him more than
seven
months to visit visit the national
institutes of health during a pandemic
so where is secretary becerra
he's like a coveted man of mystery
joining me now is florida congresswoman
kat kamik thank you congresswoman for
joining us
from florida uh congresswoman
where is this guy he's the secretary of
health and human services during a
pandemic and i never see him
jason
first thanks for having me good to see
you and uh to your point i don't know
this is definitely turned into a game of
where's waldo
no one seems to be able to find him on
really any of the issues that he has
full jurisdiction over
it could be covid which of course as you
just said he has not even been to one of
the major press conferences at the white
house which you would think that the
secretary of health and human services
would be a part of when it came to the
border issue which hhs has a major role
to play in the border because border
patrol turns over all of the
unaccompanied children
over to
hhs a whole other story he hasn't been
down there
nor has he been out front and center
dealing with the opioid
epidemic so on the major issues the
major crises that we have been facing as
americans
the health and human uh the the hhs
secretary has been m.i.a
and when asked about this i believe in a
radio interview that a reporter was able
to actually track him down
they asked well why aren't you at any of
these major briefings and why aren't you
more front and center talking about this
issue the same way that secretary azar
was and he said it's quote not the
profile that counts it's the results
the results okay we can talk about the
results there's been more people that
have died under the bite administration
from covid than under the trump
administration we have mixed messaging
across the board uh one minute the the
president is saying that you're going to
have a winter of death and destruction
and fear and in the mongering is all
over the map and then he says don't
panic and yet we have an hhs secretary
secretary barcera who has nothing to say
and is nowhere to be found it's very
very disturbing and quite frankly some
people think he may be on his way out
well look you're in the house not in the
senate so you didn't go through the
confirmation process but he barely
squeaked by because he has no health and
human services background he's an
attorney by trade he was the california
attorney general he has no background in
this so now all of a sudden president
biden's saying whoops i forgot to order
the masks well somebody's got to turn to
somebody and say whose job and role and
responsibility and you would think the
health and human services secretary
would be somewhere in the room
but i i mean
who are we supposed to turn to
well and you you look at an agency like
hhs and and the vast uh portfolio that
they oversee everything from cms
medicare medicaid we saw under this
democratic house
massive cuts to medicare and medicaid to
pay for their social justice warrior
programs and then you get still no word
out of out of the secretary on this and
again with the border no no words to be
said even though there was outrage about
the unaccompanied children and the
treatment or lack thereof under this
administration and again that's an hhs
responsibility now they're talking about
biden's signature at home testing
program no contracts have been signed uh
there's not really been any details laid
out you would think that the secretary
would be in charge of that but something
that i found interesting jason was just
a few weeks ago he was asked how are we
going to plan for this and he said well
you know we really ought to ask congress
for more money because we need to make
sure that this is an issue that stays
front and center for this administration
and we don't want to ask after the fact
are you kidding me yeah the the bind
administration is hell bent on pushing
through
this nearly five trillion dollar bbb
buildback broke
plan that is nothing but green new deal
and social justice warrior nonsense and
we have the secretary finally pop his
head up and say hey we might need some
money for covid when in reality there's
a lot that still has yet to be spent
from all of these coveted packages
and so you can start to see how this is
going to end up happening come the first
year they're going to be asking congress
for more money to run another program
yes and look you're in the house it's
primarily primarily the role of the
senate to drag him up there and say
because they were the ones that
confirmed him how in the world is this
doing this congresswoman thank you and
have a wonderful new year thanks for
joining us on the ingram happy new year